have you ever wanted to throw your PC
out of the window no through the doll
okay okay is there any difference I live
downstairs so I have an open way out to
the garden okay why what well because it
went slow have you ever wanted to throw
your PC out of the window oh yeah very
often okay I wanted to throw your PC out
of the window yeah many times why
because about our bad connection at the
at office especially at office how
important is very important because if
it's luck I can't work anymore I cannot
live without it actually what kind of
internet connection do you have it at
home I have
adsl 25 meters but at work we have to
mega oh god I'm i live in the rural area
so the internet connection is hard to
make it there and I've got a dsl modem
and it's this kind of connection and I
guess the quality of the internet the
speech isn't enough for me know hey what
what do you think would change in your
life if your internet connection was
really really really fast I would be
faster I can do more and more for for
work and to find some more stuff though
that's good I could definitely spend
less time in front of the computer
because yes yes yes because some things
could be done faster great communication
would be improved this Internet's saving
time yes so it is everything vampy
banking medicine a contact with the
other people so it is just the saving
time what do you think would change in
your life if your internet connection
was always super fast and watch a lot
more TV on the internet and spend more
time on the internet absolutely yeah I
think it will open new chances and
possibilities and I think it's a must to
have a pretty quick internet connection
it makes life a bit easier what do you
think would change in your life if you
your internet connection was always
super fast Wow very very interesting so
I can connect everywhere so connect to
my mobile phone and then come back to my
home connect to every devices I can
control my home and everything very very
nice ok I'd love it to be much faster I
think the whole life would change I work
from home I
the kids have entertainment through the
internet it will really be a life
changer what do you think would change
in your life if your internet connection
was always super fast yeah I think I
would be the happiest man in the world